andrew it's an enormous undertaking but
i think we have to start with a little
bit of a philosophical backstep which is
what we're doing over at the forward
party is is thinking through
what does it look like to build a new
kind of party
and a party that is actually oriented
around an actual civic life that is
joyful and robust and makes a difference
in people's lives we have to reorient
what is a political party um because i
think people have have first and
foremost forgotten
the the potential of a political party
and so once we kind of understand that
what we're trying to build is a
container and a community for people to
engage in a robust and joyful civic life
that that deeply impacts their
communities for good now we can think
about how you structure that
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to forward
a man who has lost more independent
political races than anyone else in the
country perhaps the head of political
strategy for forward joel searby welcome
joel
andrew great to be with you thank you
yes i do hold the distinction of having
lost more independent campaigns than any
consultant in u.s history i'm pretty
sure
well it's because you've been fighting
the good fight in a very very
principled fashion but it is not always
thus
uh you started out within one of the
major parties and became a prominent
consultant in florida before i believe
departing the republican party in 2016
which might be a familiar narrative to
some but uh you want to walk us through
your background yeah sure happy to been
doing politics for about 17 years did
not get into this because it was my
career of choice i did not study
political science
but once i got in i worked my way up
through the republican ranks uh in a
consulting firm in florida and
in 2014 i became the ceo of that firm at
the time we were the largest consulting
firm in the southeast
and i was in the process of buying that
company when 2016 rolled around and i
had just been growing
less and less comfortable with the
direction of the party i was very
concerned about the 2016 election
and ultimately that became incompatible
with uh what i was doing professionally
so
i i resigned as ceo i walked away from
that buyout and i became a political
independent and have been in the kind of
new politics space ever since so that
that sounds like it was not phenomenal
for your pocketbook
[Laughter]
it cost me a lot of money and you're
like me you're a family man so like what
what is that process like yeah man it
was hard andrew and
i'm really thankful for my amazing wife
jen who has stuck through this entire
journey with me uh but 2016 was
incredibly hard it cost us a tremendous
amount of money i was losing friends and
professional connections and i was gone
a ton
but i i don't regret it i believe that
what we were doing was the right thing
to do and i had to be true to my
conscience and what i thought needed to
be done for the country at the time and
and really that opened up what has
become a seven year journey in this new
politics space and and now is developing
into what i think is the most exciting
uh movement that we've seen in our
lifetimes in politics i can relate to
you a little bit on this but i don't
think people realize and this is one
thing that pisses me off i gotta say
is that someone like you leaves a
privileged perch in the republican party
and there are so many personal and
professional costs associated with it
and you're like a
kind of
a higher ground guy so you're not like
you know uh venting about it all the
time because like you know it's like no
one can it's like you do it same thing
with with me into a much much lesser
extent um uh so when i
said hey i'm leaving the democratic
party i have to be honest like i did not
realize it was going to be such a thing
it was uh like the day before ford was
going to be announced it's like well i
guess i can't really announce this as a
dem so let me just change this
registration and then i like posted a
a video on a blog post that was not in
retrospect i really should have made
more hay out of it i really should have
like you
their attention i know but but it's
different for you because you actually
had just such like a
rich network and matrix
of uh professional relationships and so
when you say you lose friends i don't
think people realize just how rough it
gets
um when when someone who's within one of
these
parties decides to leave yeah it really
is like uh walking away from family in
some senses
you have these
deep connections and relationships that
have built over the course of years
but what's really unfortunate and sad is
is that people will indeed cut you off
just for changing your political party
even when you don't change any of your
principles i did not change a single
thing that i believed
from the day that i was republican to
the day that i became an independent
but that's not what matters in the kind
of bare knuckles partisan world you have
to be loyal to a side
and you see that played out now in in
races where you have independent
candidates running who are very credible
who are well-funded who are serious
people um and they can't get staff
because party operatives are afraid to
work on a campaign that's not within
their own party because they will be
blacklisted they absolutely will and uh
and that's the system we've created and
it's really a problem well it is one
reason why your decision uh is so
important or was so important in 2016
so you leave the firm your wife is very
very superhumanly understanding
and then so what were your next steps
what are you like okay what the heck do
i do now well i had a mission at the
time which was i had connected up with a
couple of other guys who were thinking
similarly and trying to recruit an
independent candidate for president and
so uh i hooked up with a guy named john
kingston who was uh graciously funding a
lot of the effort and uh stuart stevens
former mitt romney operative rick wilson
and a few others bill crystal and we
were trying to find a candidate so we
spent the summer looking for a candidate
to run for president as an independent
and we talked to everybody that you
would think we should talk to and they
all told us no nobody wanted to try to
take on the two-party system even with
the the prospect of trump and clinton
which at that time was was all but
certain
uh nobody would step up and do it it was
too big of a risk they wanted to have
all kinds of guarantees for money and
infrastructure and and uh so that was
the mission that i undertook over the
course of the summer but we got to the
end of the summer and the conventions
were happening and we had no candidate i
had no job and our funder said you know
what i think that's it i'm tapped out
and so i was i was pretty distraught i
wasn't sure what i was going to do
i was
we had previously scheduled vacation to
my in-laws in illinois so i was sitting
by their garage drinking a beer trying
to figure out what i was going to do
with my life and my phone rang and the
guy on the other end says i hear you're
the guy to talk to if you want to run
for president and so
uh that guy was evan mcmullen and uh
evan and i met a couple days later uh we
walked through just how basically
impossible it was going to be but that
we thought somebody should do it and uh
he called me the next day and said all
right if you're in i'm in and four days
later we launched the presidential
campaign so
we we went out and did it on principal
we knew what we were getting into
um and and then i spent the next three
months just trying to advance evan's
campaign and do what we could well we're
going to return to evan because now he's
running for u.s senate in utah against
mike lee trump endorsed incumbent who
was sending supportive text messages on
january 6 being like hey what can i do
to help
uh so evan is one of the great hopes for
people who want a new approach to
politics and you
have obviously been working with evan
for years
uh what drew you in i mean i can speak
for myself where i think evan mcmullin's
uh true
uh patriot he
was in the cia for 11 years i mean that
that's a long haul
uh and uh was stationed in the middle
east uh doing things that he uh hoped
would
protect the country
uh came back and is trying to do what he
can to help the country but did you see
all of this in 2016
yeah when we met of course we had we had
never met before and so we got to know
each other and just listening to his
story and the sacrifices he had made
we were in a very similar kind of
headspace at the time we both just felt
very distraught about the future of the
country
we believed the republican party was was
falling apart
in on itself and that no one was doing
what was right it was so clear to he and
i what the right thing to do would be
but no one was standing up no one of any
prominence would stand up and so
um you know we really were kind of
brothers in arms in that way we very
much shared a view of the world at that
moment and uh
and i did see of course the
the bravery and the exceptional
sacrifice that he had uh
put himself through for 11 years being
uh as his friends in the cia will tell
you one of the most distinguished
operatives that the cia has ever had
he's not just a guy who was out there
trying to help he was actually
one of the very best and so not only was
he
wanting to help but he was helping he
was protecting our nation and putting
his life on the line every day and so i
deeply respected that and
i said okay let's go let's do what we
can to see if we can uh make a
difference in 2016. so evan ends up
getting i believe 20 of the vote in utah
um and now he's running for u.s senate
there he's got a real following and base
there
um but what were your next steps after
that campaign because i when you talk
about racking up losses
[Laughter]
like you're uh you've been busy since
then
yeah well i i believed that we needed a
new way in our politics i knew it was
going to be hard
but at the time the
the best thing i could figure out how to
do was to try to help recruit
independent candidates to run in a
different lane
and over the course of the next six or
seven years i ran independent
candidacies for u.s senate for governor
for u.s house for mayor's races
i did help some partisans here and there
but i also worked in the reform space
particularly around voting rights i
helped with florida's amendment four
which was the restoration of felons
voting rights here in florida
and we did win that one which was a huge
win
but just going through that kind of
reform and and new politics space i
learned a ton of lessons i i joke that
all those losses it's kind of like i've
i've been trying to take the hill for
for six or seven years
and uh i kind of know where all the
snipers are at i know where the land
landmines are planted and and i hope
that i can be of a service to the
movement as we go forward because we've
learned a lot of things about what
doesn't work and the the deficiencies
and the things you have to overcome but
we're starting to learn how to apply
those lessons in different ways and so i
take that that intervening six or seven
years as
a period of learning and continuing to
try to work out my own kind of
philosophy and approach to politics
um and really feel like we're kind of
stepping into a bit of a new a new era
here
[Music]
yeah and we'll talk about how much
excitement you're seeing around forward
i mean it is the most exciting thing
that anyone's seen where tens of
thousands of
incredible
uh everyday americans are signing up in
all 50 states i mean it's magical uh
it's
awesome one thing i i wanted to uh to
ask you about was the fulcrum theory
which is uh been put forward by a number
of people um and they thought to
themselves hey
uh to the extent that there is an
opportunity it might be to have a group
let's call it
three four
uh senators who are kind of straddling
the parties and in a polarized country
and this is one thing that a lot of
people don't understand is like you
don't need 51
of seats to control or influence policy
in this context you might only need one
or two if they're the right seats
that's right that's right so just to
give folks kind of a basic overview the
idea of the fulcrum strategy is
kind of lives in the u.s senate world
though it applies to every
governing body and it actually has taken
place in a place like alaska in the
state legislature just a few years ago
so i'll use that as an example in a
minute but the basic concept is that in
a closely divided legislative body like
the u.s senate a very small number of
senators
could and
dramatically influence the
direction of the senate
because they have the power to hold
their votes uh in in kind of together in
a way that would force both sides to to
come to the middle and have a
conversation now when i say middle i
don't necessarily mean the the
philosophical middle it's more about the
way that power brokering happens and the
decisions get made and we've seen this
in action in the recent months even with
folks like joe manchin and kristen
cinema and susan collins and lisa
murkowski they hold a tremendous amount
of power because they are willing to
broker those deals now
the fulcrum strategy takes the the basic
concept and turns it into
an actual practicing group that might
organize themselves for example as a
separate caucus
there are ways to do that i've had many
hours of conversation uh with some
deep experts in the field uh who who
really know what they're talking about
and and this can be done it's really
about the will of the senators and and
the people around them to want to do
that and it's hard it's incredibly hard
but there is a precedent in terms of how
the senate works to do that and again
the example in alaska was you had a very
closely divided legislature and you had
a handful of independent legislators
and they got to decide really who they
would caucus with who they would
organize with and so what ended up was a
a third force in the alaska legislature
that was made up of republicans
democrats and independents and they set
the legislative agenda for the entire uh
legislative session and and so this
works it has been done um and i really
believe that it could totally transform
the way that the u.s uh senate and
congress works yeah we have a golden
opportunity right here and now
to help get
one or two or three
u.s senators
who are interested in being this fulcrum
and that can be through
enlistment it can be through helping
certain people win races
uh so that they're
you know that a lot of people jump to
different uh different levels uh we're
super excited about the 500 6 000 local
races that you and i can talk about as
well um but man are there massive
opportunities uh in november for us to
have an enormous impact
yeah no doubt andrew and what we see is
again a group of senators and potential
senators who
are more and more open to this concept
because they realize that the senate is
broken they realize that the government
overall is not working
and that the divisiveness has completely
infiltrated the the policy making there
are some brave folks who are considering
uh making some changes and
i think what is going to be important is
that there is an electorate and a
political apparatus and a group of
people who are willing to say we'll
we'll stand with you that's something
that hasn't been there before in fact i
i had a conversation
a few years back with a chief of staff
in the senate about this very concept
and i've had many conversations with
many chiefs of staff
and that chief of staff told me
something very telling uh that i have
stuck with me ever since he said if your
plan
depends on the courage of the senators
it will fail
and and uh unfortunately uh he was he
was trying to make the point that uh not
not that there's no such thing as a
courageous senator we've seen some
recently
uh but that the reality of politics in
america is that there are so many uh
cross pressures that you have to be able
to give them some some support and some
relief valves very few people will put
their entire career on the line uh to
take a risk like this and so i'm hoping
that in the coming years that we can see
this real coalition develop that wants
to support this this new way of
governing yeah that's what we have to
build man i mean expecting people to do
the unreasonable self-punishing thing is
stupid
better incentives not everyone could be
a joel serbi you're never going to be a
us editor joel it's probably true
let's talk mechanics of uh party
building and you're one of the
preeminent experts
on
ballot access and blocking and tackling
there's so much ignorance in this space
so much confusion so many stupid lazy
narratives when people say this and that
and like i'm just shaking my head being
like hey guys like you know that that's
mechanically impossible what you're
describing right uh so
walk us through what the heck it means
to actually
uh build 50 state parties yeah andrew
it's an enormous undertaking but i think
we have to start with a little bit of a
philosophical backstep which is what
we're doing over at the forward party is
is thinking through
what does it look like to build a new
kind of party
and a party that is actually oriented
around an actual civic life that is
joyful and robust and makes a difference
in people's lives and so if you don't
reframe first of all at that most
foundational level and our friend
michael slaby has really helped think us
walk us through thinking about this we
have to reorient what is a political
party um because i think people have
have first and foremost forgotten
uh the the potential of a political
party and so once we kind of understand
that what we're trying to build is a
container and a community for people to
engage in a robust and joyful civic life
that that deeply impacts their
communities for good now we can think
about how you structure that and and the
structuring is actually a matter of
blocking and tackling and and tactics
that are largely driven by
a
an absolute uh web of crazy state and
local laws that are in many cases
nonsensical and almost always driven by
the power of the two major parties and
so what you have to understand is when
you build a national party what you're
doing is you're building a a federation
of 50 state parties and when you're
building a state party you're building a
federation of a bunch of county parties
and local parties and candidates and so
as you think about this and building
this community
there's there's basic things that have
to happen uh in every state and each
state has a slightly different rule set
for how that has to be done so in some
states for example louisiana you gather
a thousand registered voters and you
file some paperwork and you're a
political party
in the state of florida you can be a
minor party with just a piece of paper
and some people
and and yet if you want to become a
major party in florida like the
republicans and democrats you have to
have
715 000 registered voters and so you are
relegated to minor party status for for
a long time unless you can really pour
fuel on the fire in in the case of
florida that's what we intend to do in
other states uh you have to get ten
thousand signatures or five thousand
registered voters or in some states like
illinois you have to get five percent of
the statewide vote in a gubernatorial
race i mean the the rules are just
absolutely all over the place the bottom
line about how we have to do this though
is we organize around great people and
great leaders and we empower state and
local leaders to say how are you going
to build this party
what do you think it needs to
embody and how is this going to look now
one of the things that
i i think is being broadly misunderstood
about the foreign party right now
particularly among
the political class and particularly the
twitterrati which i try to mostly ignore
but what they're talking about is is
fundamentally missing the point of where
we're at in the process and what it
looks like to build a party because yeah
where we're at right now is much more uh
i'm gonna i'm gonna steal back some
historical narratives from the far right
here for a minute we are much more in a
space like the boston tea party moment
or maybe the declaration of independence
because that was not the revolution the
country was not born when a bunch of
people threw tea over the edge of a ship
the country was actually not born
fundamentally when they started writing
out this declaration
what has to happen is you build and you
fight and you work and you you create
over the course of an arc of time
that then builds in the the fabric of
what will become the nation and how the
nation is governed so the declaration of
independence then you had to have the
constitution then you had the bill of
rights then you had amendments
all of that is a process that we should
step back and say oh that's how
governments are formed that's how
government works
it's it's very similar to where we're at
with the forward party we have declared
we are building a new viable credible
durable party for this country
now we get together as communities of
people who want to see this happen and
we build this party and we we navigate
through all of this uh this web of rules
and laws but the good news is
it can be done it can be navigated uh
with with good patience and hard work
and lawyers we will navigate it and
that's
good lawyers
employed by the board party good
expensive lawyers maybe not so expensive
who knows
[Music]
so we're going to go after the
low-hanging fruit uh you know the states
that have
more accommodating
uh rules and regs so what are the 15
states that we are targeting in
the next uh series of weeks and months
let's say you know 22 plus a bit of 23.
get some kind of legal status in about
15 of those by the end of this year and
so we've we've used a series of metrics
basically you know we gave them all a
rating of how easy they were going to be
how difficult they were going to be
where we had people and resources
already things like that really thought
strategically through
how we can do this um and so among some
of those i can just kind of walk through
a handful here i can certainly list them
out
north carolina is a little bit of a
heavier lift but one where we have great
infrastructure and is ripe for this we
need somewhere around 13 000
uh in north carolina so that's a little
heavier lift we're getting organized
there we've got great state leaders a
place like hawaii we only need 796
signatures so i've already volunteered
to go to hawaii and get the signatures
nobody's uh signed me up yet but hawaii
isn't easy yeah no there'll be a bunch
of us volunteering that's right that's
right uh the state of state of
washington you don't actually have to do
anything you just you get candidates the
candidates are what uh determine the
status of the party so you have
candidates that run and they say i'm a
forward party candidate and that's what
goes on their ballot line so washington
is is very easy from that perspective
alaska eight roughly 8 000 signatures we
can go do that
utah 2000 signatures
in a place like louisiana as i mentioned
a thousand signatures places like uh
west virginia seven thousand signatures
uh mississippi you just put in a piece
of paper florida you you submit your
bylaws and your leadership and you're a
minor party so there's a there's quite a
few states like that where we think a
combination of really easy ones where
it's basically paperwork and a few
signatures and then some some kind of
mid-level lifts where we want to go get
some wins through organizing and getting
signatures
and again there's about 22 to 24 of
those that we'll be looking at and
already are organizing in so you have
personally been having a lot of these
conversations with excited
uh volunteers uh and activists and
organizers in various states can you
relate the
nature of those convos the type of
people that are coming in
yeah andrew this is the most exciting
part for me and this is what really
keeps me going every day on this work
because this work is hard and
the the fire hose that we are drinking
from
while very exciting because so many
people are engaged is difficult to keep
up with but these folks are really
really amazing salt of the earth uh
incredibly talented experienced people
i've been around politics 17 years i've
set in a lot of
republican and democratic committee
meetings and town town meetings
unfortunately they tend to draw very
often
not the highest caliber folks people
that are really there to either argue we
know we're talking we know what you're
talking about joel
uh to be gadflies you know it's just the
reality
this is the exact opposite these people
are really amazing you know one of our
state leads just as one example is a
woman who's in her in her 50s who is a a
very accomplished corporate project
manager c-level operator uh someone who
just believes in the mission and is out
here doing the work and and there are
hundreds of of people like tina who are
out there doing amazing work and and
it's just so inspiring to see these
people stepping up who want to help lead
this party and and we have many many
leaders in in all the states that we're
organizing we're fully organized in over
30 states we have people in all 50
states uh it's really really exciting we
have monday meetings with our state
leads we have a noon me and an 8 pm
meeting and we have over 100 people on
those meetings that are there having
conversations and and wanting to do
everything they can to get this thing
going yeah that's why i'm so pumped
right now joel is that i've been a part
of different organizations and efforts
before and you can kind of tell which
way it's going to head based upon the
people that you're attracting
so
if you get ass kickers and people who
are
motivated and determined for the right
reasons and like don't give a hang about
credit just trying to get the job done
you can move mountains and those are
exactly the people that are coming to
forward it's really wonderful and one
thing that you discovered and i
discovered you discovered a little bit
more the hard way than i did i'll say
um so so someone some people uh
occasionally
uh accuse
me of
uh
trying to
elevate myself by going third party and
i just start laughing because it's like
are you kidding me like you had this
direction and like all of a sudden like
you know like every institutional
support like disappears like a lot of
people who occupy positions of power and
influence uh want less to do with you
it's like you're freaking walking into
the wilderness like no one does this
for
the wrong reasons you know what i mean
so like the folks who are coming in
uh see the vision see the need see the
potential just want to roll up their
sleeves and kick some butt and that is
why we're going to build something
truly
awesome phenomenal that's going to
change the course of american history
i could not agree more andrew it is
so inspiring to see folks stepping into
this and
it's not only true that this is a
sacrificial move for almost everyone who
does it
but it also means that people are
counting the cost before they step in
and when you have people counting the
cost before they step in
you know you've got the right kind of
people because many of the people that
are coming to our party leadership they
are coming out of partisan positions
republicans democrats libertarians
in droves because this is what they've
wanted this is what they've been longing
for
and and now we're here and they are
ready to go to work and it is absolutely
inspiring
so i'm going to to do a little bit of
scaffolding on evan mcmullen uh which i
think is one of the most important races
and i realize that people who listen to
the podcast may
not know the ins and outs of evan's
situation uh we'll try and get evan on
the podcast and and you know have people
get to know him a bit better but i think
this is so fascinating because evan
mcmullin's running for us senate and
utah which is a state that trump won by
21 points so you think that state's
solid uh uh in in the republican camp
but the democrats of utah did something
almost unprecedented which is they
decided not to run a candidate
uh so on the ballot is just gonna be
mike lee versus evan mcmullen and so the
39 percent of utahns who voted for joe
biden probably not going to be huge mike
lee fans that there there may be uh an
enthusiasm or turnout gap uh among their
number because you know if there's not a
demo i think they'll show up to vote
anyway because you know there are other
races
to vote for but let's say that the 39
show up and all go to evan then the
question is
can evan peel off 12 of the 59 percent
who voted for trump
in the last election uh and i think one
of the most powerful
signals was that mitt romney declined to
endorse his republican incumbent
colleague uh he's just like hey you know
i'm i'm friends with both of them which
i think is like a very powerful all
clear sign to a lot of uh moderate
republicans in utah to be like hey you
know it's okay with evan like i can vote
for evan
and feel good about it yeah i think to
understand what's happening in utah you
have to step back just a bit and
understand the background of how this
came to be which really does send
signals
to those of us who care about building
something new which is that from the
get-go evan was committed to building a
cross-partisan coalition he was saying
from the start i'm going to run as an
independent and i want to bring in
republicans and democrats and
independents and united utah party and
libertarians that is the way we will be
someone who has been you know supportive
of not only the big lie and january 6th
and you know actively participating in
very dangerous undermining of our
democracy
but and so fundamentally there was a
coalition there who disagreed with mike
lee but i think even more important than
that there's a coalition of people who
want to see something different and in
places like utah you have the democrats
who have basically been shut out of
governing for decades
and you have minor parties who have been
trying to do something different but
never had kind of the lift in order to
get it done
and along comes a figure like evan who's
willing to to make himself a bit of a
figurehead in that movement
and do something that's never been done
so there's that kind of backstory of how
it came to be
but then i think it's important to
understand that what the democrats did
here was really sacrificial i have to
give them credit for what they did it
was visionary and it took a lot of work
and of course there was opposition
but what they realized was hey maybe
democracy matters more than just having
someone with a d on their name uh and
and that was really admirable and i
think patriotic what they did there
and and so i think we may see that
replicated in other places i also want
to say though at the same time uh
in some states
partisans aren't competitive because
it's a total misbalance but in the vast
majority of races of the 500 000 elected
officials
uh depending on the cycle somewhere
between 60 and 70 of those races go
completely uncontested and that is
because there is not the the right kind
of organization and energy and people
actually putting forth choices in those
races and so you have two different
dynamics you have sacrificial decisions
bipartisans that i think could happen in
republican and democratic states were
republicans of the minority as well
following the mcmullen model
and you have then also just the the vast
number of local seats that don't go
contested that could also use this exact
same theory of an independent or more
more importantly to me a forward party
candidate stepping in and building a
cross-partisan coalition yeah it's one
reason why i so badly want evan to win
this race because you could literally
coin a new phrase the mcmullen model
based upon him prevailing
and if if uh he falls short
then it'll be easy for people to be like
ah you know like nothing can change like
you know they like uh of course you
can't build a cross-partisan coalition
uh so there's a lot riding on evan
mcmullin's race you have one of the most
difficult jobs in ford one of the most
important jobs in ford there are other
people in four that envy you by the way
because you're actually talking to real
life humans that uh are making things
happen uh in communities which is the
whole point of the entire thing
uh if someone wants to help the forward
party and join
what is the best way for them to express
their support yeah number one is go to
forwardparty.com
volunteer that is where you will begin
your onboarding process we have a solid
digital infrastructure uh with a back
end that will help you get connected
with a real human being in your state
and help you get connected with state
leaders there are
weekly and monthly and bi-weekly
meetings happening in in all the states
that were organized
and those leaders will reach out to you
and make sure that you understand what's
going on and how we're building in those
states so that's that's first and
foremost certainly this is a grassroots
movement we hear a lot of chatter about
who's funding this well you can see that
we're going to be fully transparent in
the fec
uh filings but but that's kind of almost
missing the point because
any political party that's going to
sustain over the long haul
has to be a grassroots
movement that is funded and supported by
real people
with 25 a month and 50 a month uh going
into making that happen and i don't say
that at all flippantly i absolutely
reject the way that political
fundraising has become so disgusting and
gross and i hate it um and i say this as
someone who fundamentally believes that
the way this will get built is by people
who say i'm willing to give 10 bucks a
month and support it and i'm willing to
show up at volunteer meetings and i'm
going to host events in my community and
then they say you know what i'm going to
run for office i'm going to raise my
hand and say i'm going to go do this
in my community and i just talked to a
sitting city councilwoman yesterday and
this is one of dozens of conversations
i've had
who is currently serving as a democrat
she used to be a republican and she said
this is what i've been waiting for i'm
ready to move to forward as soon as
you're registered in my state and we
will be registered in her state soon so
that's another way people can get
involved talk to your local elected
officials tell them what ford is doing
and and say there is a different way you
can become a forward party legislator
and elected official well it's so vital
because each major party has essentially
completely given up on
you know
60 70 percent of the country in in many
cases i mean if you look at the map like
democrats are not competing meaningfully
in rural areas around the country uh in
various red states and republicans are
not meaningfully competing
uh in urban enclaves uh and other places
where democrats dominate so you
essentially do have one party rule in
the vast majority of the country which i
don't think anyone thinks
is a good thing or healthy
and then when you reduce the minority
party to gadfly status
you know it's one of the things again
that's so impressive about the utah
democrats because there was a
candidate trying to run for senate as a
democrat and then who was saying and
this you know in a way it struck me as a
bit ironic he was like you'll
disenfranchise us if you don't run
a democratic candidate uh and then so
you had the question it's like okay is
the point as you said uh democracy like
people maybe having a meaningful choice
and this being meaningfully contested
and maybe changing the nature of
uh politics for utah but maybe for the
entire country or
having a person with a dnx their name
that we know is going to be a sure loss
in a state that
republicans win by 21 points and you can
think about your own local race probably
if you're listening to this like you
know one party dominates that race the
other party uh frankly a lot of the time
is nominating uh really odd people or
not nominating anyone at all because
there's no real contest
and that's what we need to change and it
happens on both sides i think the
the dangers are
very different right now i don't want to
engage in both sides ism because i don't
think that's actually uh true yeah but i
do want to say i want to say clearly
that
both parties are doing this in terms of
both really failing their communities in
very specific areas where they've given
up
and
i think that based on the conversations
i'm having you're about to see a wave of
local elected officials
who finally feel like they have a
vehicle through which they can just
serve their the people of their
community one of the things that happens
in some of these local elections is
they're not interested in being
partisans that stuff happens at largely
at the federal level in the state
legislative level
the mayor of a small
town of 10 000 like my community that i
live in he's got to make sure the street
lights are working that the potholes are
fixed that the new state road that's
coming through has the right kind of
funding and the right kind of crosswalks
he doesn't have time for partisan
politics he has no interest in partisan
politics he would much rather be a part
of a party that will simply support him
that provides a vehicle for robust civic
life that has people he can connect with
and be proud of and stay out of the
partisan politics and so that's why i'm
excited that i believe he'll become a
forward party member when we're ready
and we've been having those
conversations and we'll see what happens
at the end of the day but these are the
kinds of people that really are
attracted to to the forward party right
now
that makes me so happy to hear
and i also could not agree with you more
that uh this thing will live or die
based upon whether it succeeds in
touching everyday americans becomes a
genuine grassroots movement where
millions of us stand up and say you know
what this is a much better approach than
what i've been getting
and i prefer it and i prefer it enough
where i'll actually do something i never
do which is like i'm gonna go donate 10
bucks a month um to try and support this
uh now also i'm i'm
like a very very disciplined uh operator
type where i know what it's going to
take for us to get this party off the
ground so
frankly in like you know we'll go get
the money in uh in multiple
[Laughter]
increments let's say um but uh but it
has to be a bridge to
a popular movement as quickly as
possible or else it will not work that's
right and i can tell you again that the
energy is there the numbers are there
i've been working in politics 17 years
i've tried a lot of hard things the last
seven years i've seen the metrics of say
independent senate campaigns with two
million dollars and an amazing candidate
and i know what happens when we launch
and we get great press and then there's
just kind of like a little bit of a
fizzle and you don't see the numbers
come in and the dollars don't come in
and the people don't sign up
what is happening right now forward is
the exact opposite of that i have never
seen in my 17 years the kind of
grassroots energy that is not just there
in kind of a flash in the pan way but
just absolutely committed
they are coming in and saying put me to
work
i want to get involved and and that is
something that that rarely happens in
american politics you maybe have seen it
a little bit around bernie or around you
know obama 08
you saw a little bit of that you didn't
even see that really with with trump
though he absolutely exploded onto the
scene um you didn't have people kind of
doing the kinds of
work that folks are wanting to do for
forward so i this is a really unique
moment that uh the data is telling me we
have something here the data is telling
me the exact same thing and uh when when
uh you you talk about
uh people who really rolled up their
sleeves it does make me think of the
yang gang and the people that helped put
my presidential campaign on the map so
if you're listening to this and resemble
that thank you from the bottom of my
heart and i hope you're excited about
forward uh and the work that we have the
potential to do for families and
communities around the country which
should be the [ __ ] point no no not to
you know be profane in this final
stance
but but but but people need to be the
point of these things um as opposed to
the institution being the point um so
let's go build what the country needs
joel thank you so much for your
leadership your character your sacrifice
your dedication and please thank your uh
wife and family for us as well uh you
know
[Laughter]
it's been it's been seven years for you
like for some americans have been
waiting longer some have just gotten
down to it more recently uh but but
let's go build a movement that america
has been waiting for
i agree thanks so much for having me
andrew and i couldn't be more excited
about where we're at you and me both
joel let's go let's move the country
forward appreciate the heck out of you
and uh we'll get back to work after this
combo ends
that's right
you